dit qu'elle lui ceci rocard à consommer
ces os x men dexter habitué aux
confidences des jeunes qu'ils aident ces
intervenants de l'organisme le baluchon
à saint-hyacinthe font face à un
problème nouveau comportement qui sait
quel est le triste nul pour se juger
khaled et à des jeunes dont s'occupe
l'organisme il estime que c'est le sirop
contenant du dextropropoxyphène qui l'a
fait rechuter après une année
d'abstinence depuis un boost un peu plus
et le gel depuis le 10 décembre
dans quel contexte c'est arrivé c'est un
saut je voulais tripes et puis ben
j'avais un colloque qui en consommaient
beaucoup péché qui en avait avec lui
faut que j'en ai demandé puis il m'en a
donné le dx semble que quand j'ai pris
ce bain j'ai perdu le contrôle j'ai fait
une psychose
puis ça m'a porté à rejeter sur d'autres
substances qui est ami drogue de choual
mais les plus jeunes on trouve aussi
dans leur entourage
amy n'a que 13 ans donc nous devons
protéger son identité
j'en ai mes amis on avait consommé
personnellement à l'école il se
promenait avec leur voiture mais procure
itablette de la pharmacie fakih et
chutes arrivent chercher y en a partout
genre venant des partis en ai dit je te
fais proposait quasiment partout le
monde est monde et radio xm le monde
boit souvent été sinon il ya des gens
qui mélange la 6ème avec est doté du
sens pour le temps et les peuples que
impossible de mesurer l'ampleur du
phénomène mais région sauvé il est
éducateur depuis huit ans n'en avait
jamais entendu parler avant ce printemps
quand c'est rendu que j'en trouve dans
les parcs plus qu'à des peutch de joints
puisqu'à des bouchons de bière oui pour
moi cette problématique
ce qui est nouveau ce palace et le taux
d'augmentation de jeunes qui
expérimentent ça
un sondage mené auprès de jeunes
ontariens démontrent que le nombre
d'adolescents avoir consommé du sirop dm
a doublé ce temps qu'un plan révélé
qu'en 2015
6 4% les adolescents hommes et femmes
jeunes femmes et jeunes hommes à venir
avant impression au moins une fois et en
2010 est donc deux importants ont été
rendus au dessus de 11% à ce que je
sache il n'y a pas de décès répertoriés
pour des abus de ce haut du corps au
québec pour l'instant espérons qu'un au
repos les intervenants du baluchon sont
entrés en contact avec les écoles de
leur secteur dans nokia en vol à
l'étalagé pour le revendre les écoles
après comme ça coûte moins cher que de
l'alcool ou certaines drogues puis que
ça fait à job ça se consomme bien comme
ce bonbon non plus facile tandis qu'à
acheter ce cas de la bière il ya pas de
questions qui te sont demandés l'ordre
des pharmaciens du québec a déjà limité
l'accès aux grands formats l'homme
maintenant tout ce qui est au dessus de
250 millilitres se retrouve en arrière
mais on va faire plus
on va retourner antilles un petit rappel
aux membres de s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas
de ventes multiples ôter les pharmacies
peuvent co délégué spithill oups on
arrive avec trois quatre cinq bouteilles
mais on peut dire non aux seuls
pharmaciens vont agir parce que souvent
ce que les jeunes font ils sont pas fous
ils vont rentrer ils vont aller payer
soit en avant complètement et ils l'ont
eu en avant complètement ce que les
pharmaciens là c'est vrai je conseille à
personne de franck sait pas ce que ça
peu plus conscience peu comme si on peut
comme marqueur mais ces gens et elle en
a parlé avec des adultes qui eux aussi
en savent un peu plus maintenant sur ce
phénomène déroutant ici anne louise
despatie radio-canada saint-hyacinthe